D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
GROWING OUTRAGE OVER REPORTED
PLANS TO GIVE COLD HARD CASH TO
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS IN TALKS
TO PAY UP TO A BILLION DOLLARS
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
SEPARATED AT THE BORDER UNDER
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMPS
ZERO-TOLERANCE POLICY.
EACH PERSON SET TO GET A PAYOUT
OF UP TO $450,000.
REPUBLICANS SAY THAT PLAN CANNOT
MOVE FORWARD.
>> YOU BREAK THE LAWN YOU GET
AMNESTY WITH DEMOCRATS.
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO PAY YOU
FOR BREAKING THE LAW.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM COMING TOWARDS THE
BORDER AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN SINCE
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
WAIT UNTIL WORD GETS OUT THAT
YOU GET PAID FOR BREAKING THE
LAW TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> IN -- INCOME FRANTICALLY
STUPID IDEA PASSING ON HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TO PEOPLE HIS
FIRST ACT IN THIS COUNTRY WAS A
VIOLATION OF OUR LAW MAKES NO
SENSE AT ALL.
>> IS GOING TO BE A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO EVERY HARDWORKING
AMERICAN WHO WORKS HARD AND
PLAYS BY THE RULES AND IT WILL
ESPECIALLY BE A SLAP IN THE FACE
TO PEOPLE THAT HAVE IMMIGRATED
ILLEGALLY TO THIS COUNTRY.
>> Shannon: CONGRESSMAN DAN
CLARK -- CONTRACT TWEETING THEIR
NEXT OF KIN GETS A INSURANCE
PAYMENT OF $400,000.
LET THAT SINK IN.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS SENT A LETTER
TO THREE CABINET SECRETARIES
BEHIND THE PLAN DEMANDING
ANSWERS.
JESSE, YOU BROUGHT THIS UP
YESTERDAY.
WE WEREN'T SURE.
IT'S REAL, IT SOUNDS LIKE.
>> Jesse: HE PAYS YOU TO BREAK
THE LAW.
HE FEELS YOU OUT.
HE BAILS YOU OUT.
DIDN'T HE STOP BUILDING THE
BORDER WALL AND THEN BUILD THE
BORDER WALL AROUND HIS OWN
HOUSE?
HE PUT THE KIDS IN CAGES.
THE SAME CAGES HE GOT MAD AT
TROUT FOR PUTTING PEOPLE IN.
THE SAME CAGES HE BUILT WHEN HE
WAS VP.
I THINK HE SPIES ON YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT IF YOU HAVE -- IF YOU
HAVEN'T BROKEN THE LAW AND THEN
PUT A HALF A MILLION IN YOUR
BANK ACCOUNT.
HE FIRES YOU FROM WORKING PAYS
YOU YOU NOT TO WORK.
AND THEN HE SAYS THAT'S NOT THE
DEAD OF THE NIGHT.
IT'S EARLY IN THE MORNING.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS GUY HAS SHATTERED THE
ALL-TIME AMERICAN RECORD FOR
ILLEGAL ENTRIES AND THEN BLAMED
TRUMP.
THERE WAS A REASON WE REMEMBER
WHY WE HAD TO SEPARATE FAMILIES.
DONALD TRUMP WAS FOLLOWING THE
LETTER OF THE LAW.
YOU CANNOT HOLD ADULTS AND
MINORS IN THE SAME FACILITY.
YOU CAN'T HOLD MINORS FOR MORE
THAN 21 DAYS.
HE HAD TO SEPARATE THEM TO SEE
IF THEY WERE ACTUALLY PARENTS OR
THIEVES OR KIDS GETTING TRAFFIC.
IT DID HAVE A STRONG DETERRENT
EFFECT.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN THERE WAS A
GUY WHO CAME TO THE COUNTRY, I
THINK IT WAS 11 TIMES ILLEGALLY
AND THEN MURDERED AN AMERICAN
WOMAN IN A SANCTUARY CITY.
KATE STEINLE.
SHE SUED SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR DAMAGES.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULDN'T
PAY HER.
THEY SAID NO.
THEY'RE GOING TO PAY IT ILLEGAL
TO COME OVER HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FROM OUR
FAMILIES.
WE WERE TOLD WE COULDN'T SEE OUR
GRANDPARENTS.
WE COULDN'T SEE OUR
GRANDPARENTS, COULDN'T DO THAT.
COULDN'T SAY GOODBYE TO THEM IN
THEIR DEATHBEDS.
COULDN'T HOLD A FUNERAL.
WHAT DO WE GET?
A CHECK FOR $200?
PEOPLE GET HALF A MILLION.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Shannon: AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR A COMMERCIAL BREAK.
JUST KIDDING.
JESSICA, THIS WILL BE TOUGH
MESSAGING IF THE ADMINISTRATION
STANDS BY IT.
>> Jessica: I DO NOT WANT THIS
TO BE THE LEAD MESSAGE FOR THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
WE'LL SEE IF IT COMES TO PASS.
A LOT OF THESE THINGS ARE
PROPOSALS THAT EXIST AND THEY
NEVER COME TO FRUITION.
EVERYBODY GETS HOT AND BOTHERED
ABOUT IT AND THEN NOTHING
HAPPENS BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SAY WE HAD 5,000 SETS OF PARENTS
OR GUARDIANS, WHETHER THEY WERE
RELATED TO THE KIDS ARE NOT,
SEPARATED.
THERE IS STILL 1,000 KIDS WE
HAVE FOR YOU NOT -- WE HAVE NOT
REUNITED THEM WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
THAT SPARKS OUTRAGE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
NOBODY WANTS THAT SITUATION.
940 PLAINTIFFS.
THE ACLU HAS MADE IT CLEAR IT'S
A MINORITY OF THE 940 THAT WOULD
GET ANY KIND OF SETTLEMENT.
NOT SAYING THAT I THINK IT'S
SMART TO GO AHEAD WITH THIS.
THIS ISN'T LIKE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE GETTING HALF
A MILLION DOLLAR CHECK.
>> Jesse: ITS REPARATIONS.
>> Jessica: A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T THINK REPARATIONS ARE A
BAD THING.
>> Shannon: BENT TOWARD THE
BORDER IS CLOSE BUT THERE WILL
BE THOSE WHO ARGUE IT WILL BE
FURTHER INCENTIVE.
IN CASES WHERE THEY SAY THAT
THERE IS THE PARENT AND A CHILD,
THAT'S CLOSE TO A MILLION
DOLLARS.
IT'S A DANGEROUS JOURNEY.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE ARE PUTTING
THEM IN THE MOST DANGEROUS GAME
SHOW EVER.
>> Greg: WHO ARE YOU TALKING
TO?
>> Shannon: PEOPLE.
WHO WANTS TO ANSWER?
>> Greg: THE WHOLE KEY IS YOU
CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO BE FRAMED
AS A DEMOCRAT VERSUS REPUBLICAN.
YOU CAN'T ALLOW IT TO BE FRAMED
AS AN IMMIGRATION QUESTION AND
YOU CANNOT LET THIS BE FRAMED
ABOUT SEPARATION.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
IMMIGRATION.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET TRADE DOWN
THAT HOLE.
THIS IS ABOUT DRAINING THE POWER
OF AMERICA.
IT'S SO FAR LEFT.
THERE'S A REASON BEHIND IT.
IF ILLEGALS GET A HALF A MILLION
PER ILLEGAL, WE ARE DONE.
THAT MEANS THEY CAN KEEP DOING
THIS AND KEEP DOING THIS AND
THIS IS HOW YOU TRAIN A COUNTRY.
YOUR OPENING, TURNING ON THE
FAUCET AND EVERYTHING GOES OUT.
THE ONLY SOLUTION IS FOR
AMERICANS TO SUE THE GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE TO START SUING THE
GOVERNMENT OVER THE PERCEIVED
MISTREATMENT OF A DEMOCRATIC
WHITE HOUSE.
THE AFGHANISTAN DEBACLE.
SURELY THERE COULD BE LAWSUITS
OVER THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE RESPONSE TO
THE RIOTS.
WE CAN SUE THE DEMOCRAT CITIES.
HOW ABOUT INFLATION?
THE SEPARATION THAT YOU BROUGHT
UP.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR
LOVED ONES.
THEY WEREN'T THERE IN THE LAST
MOMENTS.
THAT IS WAY WORSE THAN ANY OF
THIS.
A LOT OF THEM WERE SEPARATED FOR
THE CHILDREN'S OWN GOOD AND WE
CAN'T FORGET THAT.
IT'S A BIGGER STORY ABOUT
DISMANTLING AMERICA.
IT'S NOT ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
THIS IS THE CRAZIEST IDEA.
IT GOES BEYOND THAT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE.
READING ENOUGH TWITTER, I'M
GOING BACK HAPPY RIGHT.
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING YOU'D GET
ON A FAR RIGHT WEBSITE THAT YOU
HAVE TO CHECK 100 TIMES.
>> Jesse: IT'S LIKE NAB LIBS
FOR LIBERALISM.
>> Shannon: ARE WE
INCENTIVIZING SOMETHING
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS FOR THESE
PEOPLE?
WHAT'S THE MESSAGE?
IF YOU WERE IN A DESPERATE
SITUATION, ECONOMIC OR WHATEVER
PERSECUTION SITUATION, WHY
WOULDN'T YOU -- CAROL THE
REPORTERS DOWN THERE TALKING TO
CARAVANS OF PEOPLE SAY WE ARE
COMING BECAUSE JOE BIDEN SAID
THEY COULD COME.
>> Katie: INCENTIVIZING A
CRIMINAL CARTEL.
PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE NIGHT,
HOWEVER THEY SAY OTHER
RELATIVES.
THEY HAVE TAKEN AWAY EVERY
SINGLE TOOL WE HAVE TWO
DISINCENTIVES NOT TO BRING THE
LAW -- NOT TO BREAK THE LAW.
JOE BIDEN SAID WE COULD ABSORB
TOO MILLION A YEAR.
ON THE ISSUE OF THE SEPARATION
AND PAYING FAMILIES WHO WERE
SEPARATED, THE FIRST THING I
WOULD SAY IS IT'S A REFLECTION
OF HOW THE LEFT FEELS ABOUT THE
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
IF YOU'RE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
AND YOU COMMIT A CRIME, YOU WERE
SEPARATED FROM YOUR FAMILY
SOMETIMES FOR VERY LONG TIME AND
SOMETIMES THEY PUT YOU IN
PRISON.
THERE IS NO MONEY FOR THAT AND
THERE SHOULDN'T BE.
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE WHO BREAK
IMMIGRATION LAW, COMING TO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY MAKING A
FEDERAL LAW GET A HUGE CHECK OF
$400,000.
NO ONE ELSE GETS TO DO THAT IF
YOU'RE A CITIZEN.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS VOLUNTARILY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS IN
EL SALVADOR, GUATEMALA, THEY
WERE SENT ALONE ON THE JOURNEY
AND THEY ALREADY SEPARATED.
IT'S A WAY, AS GREG SAID, TO
DRAIN THE SYSTEM.
IT'S A REFLECTION OF THE DISTAIN
THE LEFT HAS FOR THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER AND THAT YOU SHOULD BE
PAYING FOR RULE BREAKERS.
>> Jesse: HOTELS ILLEGALS HAVE
STANDING TO SUE AND REAP THESE
DAMAGES?
>> Katie: LEGALLY THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO SEEK ASYLUM.
>> Jesse: SUING FOR DAMAGES IF
THEY'RE NOT CITIZENS?
>> Shannon: IF THEY SAY THAT
THEY ARE HERE AND BEING HELD
AGAINST THEIR WILL IN A
SITUATION LESS THAN IDEAL, THEY
CAN SUE OVER THE CONDITIONS.
LAWYERS HAVE ORGANIZED ON THEIR
BEHALF.
>> Jesse: GITMO DETAINEES
CONSUME?
NOT ALL OF THEM.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION.
>> Jessica: THEY DID NOT FIGHT
THEIR WAY TO GETTIN